we have a voicemail number. That number is two one
nine two David Pakman. Here's a little something
for you just about delusion. We have this regular
right wing caller, Troicki. He always calls in
under fake names, and I think he gives one in this
voicemail. This is a voicemail from this morning.
We know that Democrats have taken the Senate,
Democrats won in Georgia. And Troy still says that
Republicans are going to sweep Georgia. I don't
even know what it's over. The races are over.
Yes, they Pakman the other
would again call him back.
And I just want to say I
was come up. I think Georgia
Republicans are going to sweep Georgia. It's over.
I think it's going to be a close election because
if they have not been briefed as of yet.
And. Pretty much. I think he to be more
factual reporting on the Georgia candidates.
It's over. And this is so weird because that
you might think, oh, he left that
voicemail the day before the election. No,
it's been called the races have been called. And
he left that voicemail around nine thirty in the
morning on today, Wednesday after the election,
after the races have been called. So I don't know,
maybe it's someone who's not really paying
attention or who thinks the election's tonight or
I'm not really sure. But these are these are
folks who are going to continue being around. So
that's a real challenge on the bonus show today.
No charges will be filed against the officer who
shot Jacob Blake. We will be discussing
that evictions as per a new study.
Evictions in the era of coronavirus in
the US have led to more than ten thousand
additional covid deaths and four hundred
and thirty thousand additional covid cases.
Incredible. And then lastly, on the bonus
show, the Pennsylvania Republican Party
refused to swear in a reelected Democratic
senator, they have been emboldened in their
authoritarian, anti-democratic instincts by what
we have seen Donald Trump do since November 4th.
Was it now? I don't even remember. Was the
election on the third or fourth? I think
it was the fourth in claiming victory where there
is no victory in claiming that he could just take
the election if he wants. Of course he can't
and didn't. But that has become a mind virus
that has spread dangerously through much of the
Republican Party. So we will talk about that on
today's bonus show. How do you get the bonus show?
It's so easy. You go to join Pakman Dotcom and you
sign up. It takes under a minute if you want
a discount off of a membership. I believe the
regular prices are very reasonable, but if you
want a discount, I'm glad to offer it. You can
use the coupon code better. Twenty one. All one
word, no space better 21 because we're hoping for
a better 21 than was 2020 globally global sign up.
Get the bonus show. I'll speak to you that.